One, two, three.
Okay, let's go.
Let's roll the
cameras.  We're
1632,
Black against
uh    Kavanaugh
two from Turkey. Okay,
and we have ourselves
Cecilian. And are we
finally going to get an open Sicilian for
the first time in the speedrun?
No. Still no open sicilian.
But the next best thing we get are
Rosalimo. And if you're a self
respecting accelerated Dragon
player worth your salt,
you definitely need to know how to face
the Rosalmo. We have faced it once when
we were about 1300,
1320. And those
of you who watched the speedrun Assiduously
might remember that we, uh, actually faced a
very, very reasonable opponent who
demonstrated pretty good knowledge of
White's main Russell Limo ideas. And at one
point, I was even worse.
To quickly summarize what is
available to Black in this position, there
are maybe four or five reputable
moves, but the two main ones
are G Six and E Six.
And which move you should decide to
play primarily depends on what
you play against the open Sicilian.
The same, by the way, goes for
choosing a line against, uh,
two nights, C Three. If you are
a, uh,  taimanoff player
or a con player, then you
normally gravitate toward E Six
just because you get the similar
type of structure when, uh, you play
E Six. Here, if you are an accelerated
player, then to me it makes the
most sense to play the most popular move in
the position, which is G Six. Our opponent,
Castles   and
White, has sort of one
major fork in the road.
There are variations where White takes
the night on C Six. This is the sort of
traditional main line. But more
recently, a lot of top GMs have been playing
kind of a cross between a
Rosalimo and an Alipin, and playing the move
C Three, either
in this position or after castling.
So let's see if our opponent does indeed
choose the fashionable C Three variation,
which I play myself.   Well, we don't have
much of a choice. We fee in Keto, our bishop
and in this position. Okay,
rookie One. So Rookie One is, to my
knowledge, not   a, uh,
super popular move, but it's
obviously not a move like rookie One can't
be bad. White
keeps maximum flexibility.
White white keeps the option open
of taking the night on C Six.
I'm already out of theory. We're basically
on our own here. How
should we develop? If you're looking at
this for the first time,
then you're probably leaning toward
just moving the night out to F Six.
But if you watched, uh, sort of
the previous Rosalemo game,
then you might be a little bit better
acquainted with some of Black's typical
setups here. And there is a move
that I would imagine
nobody would ever want to play, unless
you're specifically familiar with,
uh, the setup that this move is a part
of.   And, uh, this move
is actually E Five. E Seven. E Five. And
it's a hard move to explain on
the basis of general principles alone,
because if you look at this move, what might
jump out at you is that it blocks in the
bishop. That's a negative. It
creates major holes in
the center. That seems to be another
negative.  And there don't seem to be
any obvious positives of pushing the pawn
out to e five. And yet that's exactly what
we're going to do. So I'm
going to zero in on the reasons for
which we play it after the game, because I
could potentially take ten minutes   to,
uh, explain why e five is an
effective move in the Rosalimo for
black. It's not an easy thing to
explain, even if I have access to the
board, but I definitely need access
to variations to, uh, help you understand
the rationale behind e five. So for now,
I'm going to play it, and hopefully the
course of the game also
teaches you a little bit about why e
five is an effective move. Knight to C.
Three. R opponent is developing normally.
Now, the first good thing about
playing E five is that the knight gets an
additional development square. And as
you know, when there's a bishop on B
five and it's making contact with the knight
on C six, it's generally a good idea
for the knights to link up right when the
knights link up, that just is
a compact, nice way
of developing. And by playing E
five, we are opening up for ourselves a
square on E seven for the night where we're
going to put it night G to E seven.
And we're going to follow up, of course, by
playing to pawn to D six.
Another positive of the pawns on
E five and C five. Much like in the marotzi
bind, which White can play against the
accelerated, these pawns are
combining to seriously clamp
down on the D four square. In fact, that
square is protected 1234
times by our pieces and ponds,
making it virtually impossible that White
is ever going to play D four. And
our opponent plays D three, which is not
such a big deal, but White's a little bit
more cramped in the Sicilian
when they don't play
D. Okay, so here
we can obviously castle kingside,
but I would prefer for us to start
by playing the move D six. I don't like the
fact that the bishop is closed off by the
pawns and holding off on castling
can actually bear fruit.
So, for instance, if White plays bishop
to G five, we can
conceivably play H six and
then G five. And if we're not
castled yet, we can actually keep
our king in the center or even castle
it to the queen side. And then
we'll have carte blanche on the kingside
just to attack with our ponds.
Whoa. Java hookiese of the 5000 bits.
Holy smokes. Let's go d
six      and
not castling. Castling a little bit
later than you normally would is a
very advanced technique that needs to be
done with tremendous amount of caution.
Because if you could leave your king in the
center too long, that comes with a lot of
risks. But here we benefit
directly from the way we've positioned our
pawns. Right. White is never going
to be able to open up the center. D Four is
never a possibility. And so keeping the king
in the center is a totally
sensible course of action. There we go.
There's bishop g five. There's bishop g
five. Uh,     so
we have basically
two ways in which we can set
our kingside pawns in
motion.     And this is going to
be some very, very advanced positional
chess. We can play the move. H
six. But what is my
worry,   uh, in regards to the move
H six? My worry is not that White is going
to drop back to H Four. That runs right into
our scheme. We're going to play G Five, and
then we can play H Five later. That looks
great.   My slight worry is that
after H six yeah, exactly. White
takes on E seven, we can't take
back with the knight, we have to take back
with the queen. And then White plops the
knight on D five with tempo,
forcing our queen back. And then White
pushes the CPUN out and potentially
prepares D four.
So black is fine? There we would castle
kingside and the game would continue. I
think you added for the ten subs. Oh, my
gosh. But I think there is another
way in which we can achieve our main
plan of essentially attacking
on the kings side without
allowing White to take this
night on E seven and establish control of
the important D Five square. And this is a
move that obviously
your brain automatically cancels
out because of its reputation. But
I don't think there's anything inherently
wrong with it in this position, anytime the
center is completely closed, you can often
play moves that, with an open
center, would be totally unthinkable because
of how weakening they are. But, uh, I
like to move half stakes here.
Bishop comes back to E three. Maybe our
opponent would have done that anyway against
H six. Okay, so since the
Bishop comes back to e three,
I think we need to change our
plans slightly. Against Bishop H.
Four, we would have played G. Five.
Now we could still play G five and then H
five, and that's a viable scheme.
But because the move G Five no longer comes
with tempo, I think we should instead
make the emphasis on completing our
development. And especially, any time you
play F six, you have to be very
careful about the A diagonal,
which you weaken. And that's why F six
is often accompanied by the
Bishop development to E six. We're
just covering the diagonal that we just
weakened. Our opponent continues to play
instantly.  So we've completed our
development of everything except our
king.    We could consider
castling queenside here, but I would be very
worried about White blasting open
the queenside with like, A three and
B four. So let's play things in
a slightly more,   uh,
tame manner. And I think we should just
castle Kingside. I think the time has come
for us to Castle Kingside. Our
opponent might be preparing Bishop H Six,
but our bishop is not really the pride of
our position.    I
totally don't mind giving it away, uh,
or trading it off. And I actually
think we have a very nice position.
What really hurts White
is his inability to push D
Four. White really doesn't have anything
sexy going on any side of the board.
While we have superior control
of the center,
visually, our pieces might look more
passive and our pawn structure might look
sketchy, but it's not sketchy at all. We
don't have a single weakness in our
position. We have managed to defend the
square on D Five with two of our
minor pieces making 95
impossible. Okay, now we need to
transition from sort of the developmental
phase to the phase where we
actually transform
our development, our nice development,
into something concrete. And the position
is closed, which means we need to be very
patient and we need to put the emphasis
on    kind of
gradually improving our position.
Nothing happens  too
fast in positions like these.
Okay? So let's think about what's available
to us.    HM.
I'm going to take a moment to think here.
I have a pretty cool
idea.    And again, we
are violating rules left and right. Like,
this is another move that
violates,  uh, a
positional rule. And not only that, but it
contradicts what I just said.
Well, we have put two of our minor
pieces such that the D
Five square is protected and the
A diagonal is
guarded by the bishop. But
since we have Castled Kingside,
a potential White bishop check on
C four is not dangerous at
all. Our king just moves over to H
Eight. So the weakness of that
diagonal is no longer essential.
And I think our knight on E Seven
is   perfectly
capable of guarding the D Five square on its
own. Right. Notice that if White puts a
knight on D Five, let's say our bishop isn't
there, and we take back. White has to take
back with a pawn. And you know that
weak squares are best occupied with a
piece if they're occupied with a pawn,
that's not dangerous for us at all.
In fact, it gets rid of our weakness for us.
Nimzovich was the first to sort
of formulate that idea. So what
idea am I really getting at here?
Well, there's a weird move that may
seem to fall prey to one muvitis,
but it's actually a threat which is
quite hard to parry. And I'm
talking as, ah, some of you are indicating
about the move bishop to G Four. Now, what
do we even want well, obviously we want to
take the night and completely ruin White's
kingside pawn structure. They might say,
well, didn't have a knife. Said previously
that you shouldn't make moves that only
intend to ruin pawn structure. So
again,    it's not the pawn structure
that's important, it's the fact that White's
king is on the kingside. So if we're able to
take on f three, we will plop
our own knight on the equivalent weak
square on D four, and we'll already be
threatening a fork. And our queen has
very easy access to that h three square.
So we're actually trying to deliver
checkmate. That's the point of bishop G four
and that night on f three. This is the sort
of motivation behind this move.
Doesn't have all that many retreating
squares. In fact, it only has one and
that's super ugly square
on h four. Okay, obviously we take back
now. If White can't move the
night, then White has to defend it. But
there's also not that many ways to defend
it. The bishop can't jump over the
pond   if White goes
queen to e three. And this is really what I
had to see. Or rook to e three. We have a
very nice follow up and we
start taking control of the initiative.
The rook and the night are in forkable
squares. You have to notice that.
So if a pond appears on D four,
that's a fork. So the move
stems very naturally from
that observation.
Yeah, f five is a great move here. I think f
five is actually a
viable alternative.  In fact, it
might even be better than what I was
planning to do. Let me think about this
again for another second. Uh, the move that
I was thinking about, of course, is knight C
six to D four.   But
after night T four, white has this very
weird defensive move.
The knight actually now has the e
one square as a retreating
square. So f five
is a phenomenal alternative. We are trying
to drive that pond down to f four,
kick the rook out of the way, and
then take the night on f three. I really
like both of those moves.
So 94,
91. I'm just trying to find a
follow up in that position. If we find a
good follow up, we'll go 94. I mean, we
could play f five in that position.
Absolutely.     Or
we could play f five in this position. It's
one of those things. Both of these options
look so good.     But what I
like about the move f five
is that
it also threatens to win material.
Like if White moves the night,
then we play f four
and we potentially trap the
rook.   HM. This
is actually a very hard choice,
and I'm not, uh,
pretending to be thinking. I'm actually
trying to assess both of these
options. Okay, let's go for our initial
intention and play 94. I think this move is
going to be very hard for White to, uh, to
face. Practically speaking,    I
vote 94, and I'm the dictator
here, so sorry.
Okay, well, the move
worked like a charm.
Okay, now I think I know what our opponent
has missed. I think our opponent wants to
go rook to G three. In a way,
I wish we would have played F five, because
that, uh, would have been a little bit
more meat on the bone. What our opponent
forgot about is that when we take the night,
we're simultaneously attacking the queen.
Right? That is something I didn't
point out. And now our opponent starts
thinking    we faced a couple of players
now who've just played the opening and early
middle game face instantly, and then
only start thinking when they blunder
something.      Now, the game
is far from over. We've got an extra piece
for a pawn, but
we still have a little bit of work to do.
Okay? Well, I guess not.
We would have dropped our bishop back to E
six, and then deployed our
queen over to B six,
and then brought our rook to C eight. I
mean, all the pieces really come in,
but that was a pretty
anticlimactic ending, unfortunately.
Okay, let's have a look.
Let's have a look.
So we face the
rosalemo,    and
then we play the movie six.
And
when we face this for the first
time, I gave you sort of a
general rundown of
the possibilities that both
sides have. So I would sort of redirect you
to that video. I won't just repeat myself
in that game. We did
face Bishop, take C six,
and then we took back with
the deep on in order to open up to Bishop.
And we actually played something very
similar,   uh, to what we did in this
game.   I think White played D
three, and let me see if I
can find that game.
Was it this guy?
No, this is the guy
who     played a
pretty darn good game. This might have been
in the previous speedrun.    Just
trying to find,   uh, this
guy. This guy?    Yeah, this might have been
in a previous speedrun, so I won't
look too hard for it.
No, it wasn't this game either.
Anyways,
I, uh, think what we faced was
bishop C six, DC. D
three. The point I'm trying to
make is that in this position,
I think we played Bishop to G four,
we traded the Bishop
for the night,   and then we
played the move E five.
No, we didn't play bishop G four.
We just played E five straight away.
So it's the same
general type of pawn structure, which is
aimed at preventing D four and
establishing kind of a
very watertight clamp
in the center. And there's a lot of theory
in this position. So I'll, uh, redirect you
to that other game.    Here we
faced a fundamentally different
setup where White does not
take the night on C six,
and, uh, as I said, the move C three
here has gotten exceedingly popular.
It's actually the recommendation of Wesley
in his E four course. I have played it with
White. And here, the main line goes, much
like in the elephant, by the way. Night f
six. Now, the old move, which I've played
a lot, is to play this literally like
an elephant, e 595,
D four. But, uh,
black equalizes here pretty
easily after CDCD,
um, Black
Castles,  knight C
three. And to my knowledge, the best
move here is to drop the knight back to C
seven and quickly try to
smash through the center with D six.
Um, there are some crazy
lines here where white plays bishop G five.
I had a couple of blitz games like
this     takes
a six.   And here,
White has this move, knight to D
six.     Using the pin
against the EPON. Things get wild
here. There's a line where black plays H
six, white drops back in, black plays
G five, and it looks like black is one
apiece,     uh, because
if the bishop moves, then you take the
night. If the knight moves, you take the
bishop. But white has this sacrifice on G
five.   And after
HG, white sacrifice is another
piece. And here there is a move which
almost nobody knows. If
you don't find this move, you lose the
game. So, almost everybody who
I've had this position against in blitz,
they take the night  and stumble
into queen H five. And the
point is, okay, black can give up the queen,
but that's basically losing.
But the move, Rookie Yate, may seem like it
yields a draw because white is two pieces
down. So it you. It may appear that you have
to repeat moves, but you don't. White is
completely winning after queen G six,
threatening mate. And now the
very Zen move, f four is
just crushing because white threatens F
five, F six. And these pieces are totally
unassailable. There's just nothing. Black
and Dublic is not developed. So, for
instance, after 94, you just rushed the pawn
down f five. This is a cool
line.   Def six, it's
just made.   And
just the power of
a couple of well placed attacking
pieces.
Rookie six. Okay,
rookie six, where
F, uh, four. Rookie six is the top
engine move. But now you go here,
here, or sorry, you
go queen H seven,
check.    You force the
king onto the F file so that there's an X
ray. And now you play F five.
Beautiful stuff. Queen g
five. Fe is a check. That's why we
gave that check on H seven.   And here
there are some beautiful lines. You give
another check with a rook, and you can
take the bishop on G seven. But even better
is to set up a discovered mate
against the king with queen G
eight. And look at this. Mate 97, rook
F six, double check and mate.
Just amazing
mating position. Both pieces. I love it when
both pieces, when it's a double mate and
both pieces are hanging. Just
the power of the double check is on display
here.    Yeah, no,
these are really cool lines. So that's why I
like this so much for white.     But
there is a party pooper. And by the way, uh,
f five, rook h six traps the
queen.   And here there is
a showstopper for white. I'll let you guys
try to find white smooth.    And I know
we're not flipping the board because I don't
want to flip the board too many times. We
are ultimately looking at this from
black side. So,
um, you'll have to bear with it. White to
play and win.     Beautiful
move. You're going to be down three
pieces at some point. Not queen
g six. If you play queen G
six, it's just one check. And then I'll
move my king to G eight. You run out
of gas.   Knight to
e six is correct. So the right idea to open
up the f file, but you do it by
sacrificing the least amount of material.
So if black moves the king,
then the queen is
free to go. Takes takes
check. White is down three pieces and that's
it. King has to move
and the queen meanders past the bishop and
delivers, mate.    Uh,
technically the best move is rook f six. But
now you actually play rook takes f
six with the idea bishop f
six, queen f seven, mate.
So this is very enjoyable stuff
and all of this is uncorked.
Once you play f four, you have to know this
move f four.    So I could show
you more lines, but you kind of
get the gist of it.   So the
problem is that there is a party pooper in
this position.   The party pooper is
this move f seven, f six. I mean, very
hard move to play, but, uh, the move
should make sense. The piece that you
really need to eliminate is this
knight on G five. That's the bane of black's
existence. And the position is very
unclear. White plays e
takes f six. Now, again,
if you play EF, which people have done
against me, suddenly the queen moves to the
other side of the board. Queen b three
check. And obviously there's a
four.      Right? As
I said, any time you push the f
pawn, you have to keep tabs
on the a two ga diagonal and vice
versa. Obviously, if white
checks here, black has e six.
So after EF, black has to
play rook f six. And I think
according to modern engines, black is
slightly better here. If the game goes on,
it's just a super complicated position.
Black has a piece, but white has two pawns.
And white as this monster night. And you
can analyze this on your own. I haven't
plugged this into stockfish 15, so I don't
know what the current assessment of this
line is. Now, long story short, this is
not forced black. And also, for
example, if he wants to avoid this,
take on C three and play the line, which a
lot of people play against me in blitz,
which is takes in D six. But I was always
under the opinion that in a position like
this, white is a little bit better.   Um,
but perhaps bishop B six
kind of clamping down on the light squares
is the equalizing line.
So, anyways,  the thing
is, recently, almost everybody is
playing the move rook to e one.
And this is what Wesley recommends. And the
point is to avoid
playing e five and to play D four in one
fell swoop. And
here you get a position where white has
control of the center, but black counter
strikes with D five. And this is a
very theoretical position.
Karawana Carlson you
can find tons of super games
in this position.
It appears that white might be slightly
better, but the jury is still out. So this
position is super topical.  There's. Um
night c three. There's bishop to e three. I
mean,   there's a ton of different types
of moves here. I think Wesley
recommends this and
then     like, night BD
two. So,
yeah, white is a little bit better here, I
think. In any case,
um,   in any
case,    hopefully we'll get another
roast limo. And I'll delve a little bit more
extensively into the theory. From lax
perspective, our opponent went rookie
one, and we immediately play this
movie five. So, hopefully, I did a
halfway decent job of already
explaining what the rationale is behind
this move.    And,
um,   it's one of those things
that visually looks extremely
unappealing. But the more you look at it,
the more you understand that the
purported defects of this move
aren't all that bad. So
let's go one by one.
First of all, it blocks in the bishop.
Well, as I've said before, when you have a
construction with a bishop and a pond,
I like to think of this as one unit. The
pond is like an extension of the
bishop. Yes, the bishop controls less
squares. But if you think about it, the
bishop and the pond are both controlling the
D four square. They're like
part of the same machine.
And if you think of it that way, then the
bishop stops looking that bad.
Um, okay, next
point is that it weakens the D five square.
Yeah, but as you saw, we're able to put a
knight on e seven and potentially a bishop
on e six. And it's actually very hard for
white to occupy the D five
square. As for the D six
square, we're going to put a pawn there. So
that weakness is going to be eradicated.
And, uh, the plus of this move is
just that it controls the center in such
a robust way.
Okay, so why
plays knight C three? We get
our knight out to
E bishop
G five. And here, I actually really,
really like the move F six. Another move
which looks very unappealing.
H six was possible,
but again, I did not want
to allow white to
accomplish the task of getting the 985.
But really, this is not bad for black
either. I really don't think that black
is any worse in this position.
And if you play the Smashnikov's
Sicilian, you will know that these types of
positions are not that bad for black because
black has the very typical plan of going f
seven, f five,
and,   uh, essentially getting stuff
going on the kingside. Good
pieces don't win games. The night on d five
is annoying, but black and black can live
with it. Black can go around
it. And white does not have a clear plan
in this position because, okay, white can
try to go d four, but that ain't going to
cut it. I mean, white just loses a pawn.
So white is plagued by the fact that he
can't open the center. Black has no other
weaknesses. So white is sort of at a
dead end here. The engine move is a
four, and that's a sign that
there is just nothing really sexy that black
can do here. I would move the king away
to h eight so that there's no
shenanigans on this diagonal when we play f
five. Okay. Bishop c four.
And already black can seriously contemplate
playing f five. Yeah, the engine basically
says that white should    okay,
white EF is the engine move. That's not a
very human move to give black these
pawns. This has actually happened.
G three. I see a game in
the database. Wow, this is interesting.
I wonder who was playing
bishop D seven, night h four,
bishop e eight,   f ah
four,    queen D seven.
Complicated position.   So anyways,
we were spoiled for
choice     in this
position where we could have played ah h
six. But I wanted to prevent white from
achieving his aim and playing f six,
bishop B three, bishop B six.
And again, here,   our
plan would change based on
where white put their bishop. So in the
event of bishop h four, I was seriously
contemplating g five,   bishop
g three, and h five. And just
look at this bishop and how it's biting on.
Granted, this bishop is terrible. We're
threatening to win the bishop, and if white
plays h three, we just go
bang and then bang. And this is why we
keep the king in the center, not just
because the king would be less safe on the
kings, but also because we actually want the
rook to be on h eight to support,
to support the move h three.
This idea also
occurs very frequently in
the Italian, very frequently in the Italian
where you can keep your king in the center.
And this furious lightning
pondstorm on the Kingside
can often result in checkmate,
especially if white puts a pawn on h three
prematurely because that pond can be used as
a hook. This move, g four is a. Lot more
dangerous when there is a pawn on H
three because white is essentially forced
to take and now there's nothing white
can do about this pin. Moving the
queen results in
disaster because it allows bishop takes
F three.   And I had a
game,   uh, in the
Italian where I think I
demonstrated    these
types of ideas
in a completely different opening. Let me
see if I can dig it up really quickly.
This was actually one of my nicer
games on the black side of an
Italian.     It
was a pro chesley game
where I just decided to go all out
and it worked. Justin
Tan is now a GM from Australia, was
an im. We play this game.    Here we go.
So let's flip the board because we're
looking from black side. So this was an
Italian,
okay? So while we play
in the normal Italian moves, and then he
plays H three, and I'm like, okay, the
guy plays H three before
I castle. So the normal move for black is
just to cast. But I just listen to that and
I'm going to use that pond as the hook. And
here's what I do. H six,
freaking G five
and G four. I don't give a damn.
I'm just taking with the bishop. We got a
very similar situation.   He takes it
whatever night, h ah five,
queen F six, knight F four. I mean, all the
pieces are coming in. He's doing nothing in
the center. My center is perfectly well
defended. Rook g eight.
Uh, and this is why it's so good.
My king in the center is perfectly safe.
He's not doing anything to it. Bring the
other rook into the game. Bring the night
into the game.   And
ultimately, he started taking my pawns,
but     I won his
bishop. And then I brought
my bishop back and sacked the rook on
G three. This is a really nice
game. He can't take it
because then I take it and mate him on
H three.
And I
just destroyed him. I just took all his
freaking pieces. All of them
mate.
It's funny that his king ends the game on C
one. It runs all the way to the queen side
only to get mated there. But I could show
you a million games like that. This H six
G attack
is very dangerous.
And it's very dangerous when the
center is closed and when your king is
relatively safe in the center. So
hopefully
this made some sense and gives you
a new perspective on these attacking
ideas.    So
that's why we would go G five. But after
bishop E three,   black
could still go G five, actually.
But I don't love this move
when it doesn't come with a gain of
tempo,     uh,
because it's harder and it takes longer to
get stuff going on the kingside. But, uh,
we still could have considered. Instead, we
decided to play this more conventionally
with bishop E six.    And
here I think white starts stumbling.
Queen D two is a bit of an aimless move.
And this plan that White carried
out of trading dark squared
bishops is a total waste of time. Uh, just a
complete waste of time. In fact,
it also deprives the knight of
this square. How would I play here with
white? Well, what I would do is go by the
logic of, uh, exchanging Black's most
important piece. The bishop on e six is an
important piece because it controls
the light squares in the center. I would
play this move bishop to C four.
Now, definitely Black does not want to take
that. Opens up the D file and allows White
to attack D six. We would probably go queen
E seven. And now I would
move the night away from D two and try to
quickly push f four. Basically beat black to
the punch. Although, according to the
engine, black is better after f five. So
White's king starts feeling pretty
uncomfortable with things opening up.   So,
I don't know, I think Black's position is
just very comfortable here. Stop. Engine
move is like, again, a four engine doesn't
really know what to do. And then Black
already will play f five
as we were planning. But still,
I think perhaps trading and then playing f
three gives White a very solid
position,   double edged.
So I think bishop C four
was the best bet for our opponent. But as
you can see, just
playing this with White and not
opting for one of the two main plans,
either taking early or going
C is just very
difficult. White has really stifled here.
Bishop to G four, which I think was
a really good move after rookie
394, is really
the beginning of the end for White. Now he
token lost the game immediately. The only
move here would have been to drop the night
back to e one. And here we were planning to
play off five. And what I needed to see
is that after H three, what should
Black do? Who can tell me the
key idea for Black? This is what I
spent a little bit of time trying to
calculate.   Yeah, it's f
four. So you ask, what happens if I do it
anyway? And the rook is
trapped. White takes it. You take it.
That's not the end of the story. Black has
some work to do. But after
NB five night B five LPDO, the
night is undefended. The pawn is undefended.
Bang. That's a fork.
A four, a six. Get. Chase the night
away, take the pawn. And now you're a full
exchange up, and you're completely winning.
And all this time, the knight on e seven is
playing a purely defensive role, but a very
important role. It's guarding the T five
square. It's okay for a piece to play
a purely defensive role. Thank
you, Mr. Loopy.
So, anyways,
the situation after f five is already
very dire. It's like minus two
white has to somehow stumble and
bubble his way around just to save the rook.
But after f three, we still
play f four. Doesn't change anything.
So
the situation is terrible for White.
Obviously, this loses the
game on the spot and
that's unfortunate. But after
94, I think we're already close to winning
now. At the end, we would have played Bishop
back to E six and then maybe D five rookie.
The the conversion process here is very,
very straightforward. Also, the rook is
terrible. It's just doing absolutely
nothing. It's out of the game. That makes
things even worse for White. That was
a bit of an anticlimaxic game. Only
16 moves, but still a lot
of positional concepts, uh, at play
there. But.